[موسيقى]
يحكي لي انه مش انت اللي بتحددي احنا اللي
بنحدد وانت ما الك مسافه شخصيه ومين انت
كان وكل ه الاشياء فانا مجرد ما دفعته
ابعده عني مباشره كل المحققين اجوا يصيح
والكل انه يضرب كشوي ايدي واجري وعصبوا لي
عيوني وسحبوني على الارض ويخبط وي
[موسيقى]
بالحيطان
mter
[موسيقى]
قالوا لاحد المعتقلين اعترف وحين رفض
قالوا له اذا لم تعترف فناتي والدك وزوجتك
الى هنا وحين قال انه لا يصدق ان يفعل ذلك
استدعى والده وزوجته ليحضر له الملابس ثم
جعلوه يسمع صرخات زوجته عبر النافذه والبس
والده معطفا عسكريا يرتديه السجناء
[موسيقى]
عاده
واسرائيل لم تستجب لنا وانا بحملها
المسؤوليه الكامله انها هي بالخطا الطبي
اول شيء وبالا مال الطبي ابني كان قتل
متعمد